sept ans de mariage et une rupture ultra
médiatisé la demande de divorce de kim
kardashian et kanye west a été acté le
19 février
les documents du tribunal de los angeles
ont été publiés ce dimanche par le
tabloïd the sun le journal britannique
révèle également des dessous de cette
rupture à l'amiable dans l'intérêt de
leurs enfants nord sainte chicago et
psalmon les enfants kardashian ouest
semble être l'une des principales
occupations de cette séparation qui m'a
entre autres expliqué vouloir les
préserver au trouble de son ex compagnon
atteint de bipolarité
la mère de famille aurait mis sur la
table une proposition de garde alternée
une option satisfaisante pour le rappeur
aucun des deux époux n'aurait par
ailleurs de pension alimentaire à verser
kim et kenny serait également tombé
d'accord concernant la répartition de
leurs biens notamment de leur propriété
à calabasas près de los angeles pour
protéger leurs fortunes respectives 747
et 830 millions de dollars il avait
signé en 2014 un contrat de mariage lors
de leur union
et si face à cette séparation qui me
garde la tête hors de l'eau kanye west
se serait retiré dans son ranch wyoming
où ils préfèrent s'isoler
donc il n'a pu protéger sa fortune
estimée à 2 milliards de dollars mais
c'est considérable c'est considérable
ouais moi ça me rappelle le divorce
angelina jolie avec brad pitt qui n'est
pas terminée et qu'il n'est pas fini
ils se battent pour le château le
divorce ils ont déclaré choix le 30
septembre 2016 le divorce en avril 19 ça
y est le divorce est prononcé tout va
bien mais là ils repartent en charge
parce qu'il avait comme six enfants chez
les brad pitt angelina jolie
donc c'est compliqué un qui va garder
alors généralement aux états unis la loi
est faite pour ce soir en priorité les
mamans et en france
oui en majorité en même temps ils ont
raison oui c'est mieux même temps là
dedans alors quand même ils ont quand
même pris une avocate spécialisée des
divorces des stars 1 qui s'occupait de
johnny depp dans des jolis justement de
bd spears de ryan reynolds de miley
cyrus ou encore de six länder
alors vous savez alors à donald donne
des conseils que j'aurais bien aimé
avoir à l'époque
écoutez bien les cinq conseils de 7,2
cette avocate renommée elle prend 6 en
dollar de l'heure 6 ans de labeur et
c'est correct ça commence à compter
il faut rester zen et élégant ça c'est
le premier conseil l'avocat n'est pas
votre psy très bons conseils
l'intérêt des enfants d'abord ça c'est
vrai ça c'est vrai ne vous arrêtez pas
de vivre ça on avait compris et surtout
la loi pas les mois la loi pas les mois
il ya toujours dans tous ces divorces et
séparations célébrités ou pas il ya
toujours un problème d'ailleurs si la
femme est partie à quelqu'un d'autre si
le mec est parti avec une autre parce
qu'il ya ça qui intervient
psychologiquement mais je connais bien
la rupture que je connais bien je sais
que vous connaissez bien
vous avez un peu d'avancé sur tous les
français j'ai quelques divorce voilà est
alors alors cette notion civile et
psychologique on en tient jamais compte
on parle beaucoup des enfants beaucoup
des biens matériels rible mai mais
souvent il ya une haine de l'un ou de
l'autre
si en a fait sa vie si parce qu'ils ont
toujours un problème sexuel derrière
alors alors alors on va donc pas rentrer
dans les détails pour l'instant mais
c'est vrai que quand vous voyez votre
votre ex à la une des magazines et
quelqu'un d'autre forcément on lui pas
très bien voilà l'image images et
voilages et moi je vous dis ça je vous
en parlais je ne sais pas comment ça on
peut le vivre mais j'imagine qu'on le
vit pas bien voilà j'imagine